let's move on to more pressing political
stuff a friend of George Clooney's says
he might be jumping into the political
arena we've got a quote he has big
ambitions and aims to get into politics
imminently he wants to do more
humanitarian work in hopes to join the
Democrats 2016 election campaign George
is thinking of how he can get more
involved now he has a mile by his side
it will give him more credibility to run
for office of course this is a friend of
George Clooney's Clooney obviously is no
stranger to politics
he helped Obama get reelected in 2012 he
does a lot of political fundraising he's
been involved in Darfur he's also
married British lawyer Amal alamuddin
and she defended WikiLeaks Julian
Assange and she's a Human Rights
specialist so obviously he has interests
that go beyond just acting and the
reason I wanted to do this story because
of course this is just conjecture and
it's one friend that's saying this but
I'm a firm believer that the way
everything's heading in this country
we're going to just start voting in
celebrities I mean Hillary is already
becoming more of a celebrity than a
politician and Obama was sort of a
celebrity candidate and I think that's
the route this is going for better or
worse is this is this net bad or net
good this this celebrity political
mumbo-jumbo depends on the celebrity but
I think it's an issue when we take
someone celebrity status or for example
Arnold Schwarzenegger like macho skills
and you know power in movies and
transfer it over to the real world I
think that's the issue when we assume
that these characters that they play on
television are actually part of who they
are right so you wanted Schwarzenegger
like bust into the Capitol in Sacramento
with a gun no no I wanted him leashed a
baby but that's a different story I just
think that it's kind of crazy how we all
know matically attribute sort of
characteristics to celebrities and
assume that that's who they are I think
that's why people fall in love with
celebrities they don't realize that
they're actors right so that's the part
that I think is really interesting about
this because if you look at Clooney he
looks presidential right people people
like him he could play the president
very easily he played a presidential
candidate before where would it leave it
what's called The Ides of March did not
see that
this is courtesy of Ben mankiewicz and
Turner Classic Movies would you vote for
Clooney would you vote for me no because
on one hand like he seems like he's on
the right side of things he's Pro gay
rights he did a lot of work for Darfur
before anyone else did the other hand he
might be a little bit of an Obama crony
like what happens when his idealism gets
kind of crushed and he's surrounded by
these people that say you did this you
did that and he becomes a different man
he's not strong enough I mean we work
out but what I found really funny about
that quote was it was kind of intimating
like oh now he's ready now that he's
about to have a wife because he's
qualified right he's getting this wife
so suddenly if you have a wife then
obviously you can be you can be
President
just to clarify what I was saying
earlier I don't think that the celebrity
thing and politics is like a net good in
general but I do think there's maybe
like a little room where having people
that are already rich and already
popular maybe would be a little more
honest because they wouldn't be beholden
to all the all the corporate interests
maybe maybe a little bit I know it's a
slippery slope and even as I'm saying it
it sounds kind of gross the politicians
who started out celebrities and one were
conservative so the only I can think of
are Al Franken and well maybe it wasn't
Ashley Judd was going to yeah so she
didn't maybe it's not the worst thing in
the world yeah do you guys think we need
what they have in most European
countries a president and a prime
minister so one the president that sort
of the celebrity that does all the
ceremonial stuff and then a prime
minister that actually does what our
president does like actually does the
work because I think that might help if
we were able to get some of the like
paparazzi stuff off with the president
and then have someone else that was
actually doing the work do you think
that would help I feel like that kind of
happens already I mean I don't assume
that President Obama is they're actually
doing something you know I could but I'm
I feel like they probably he probably
has a certain set of responsibilities
our president does write and then the
others are divvied up right but don't
you think so much of it is just going to
the fundraisers showing it but these
events as opposed to doing the work I
think you agree with me right
yeah absolutely yeah it's a lot for 1% I
just think that they already kind of
divvy yet dig it up what do you think
should we have a president and a prime
minister I'm sorry we're not a monarchy
yeah you know Bob oh wow
it might be I don't know about that I
don't know about that one Dave no no no
all right my crazy idea I want to turn
this a little more into Europe all right
I'm nuts okay